i
[Música]
los presidentes de eeuu y rusia reiteran
sus posiciones sobre la crisis de
ucrania en llamada telefónica a ambos
jefes de estado abordaron temas de
seguridad como antesala de la cumbre
binacional del 10 de enero
un récord a diario de más de 13 millones
de nuevos contagios de kobe de
1924 horas la organización mundial de la
salud dice que detrás de estas cifras
está la combinación de la incidencia de
las variantes delta iv o milton
al menos cuatro muertos deja una nueva
jornada de manifestaciones contra la
cúpula militar en sudán
miles de ciudadanos se exigen que los
militares responsables del golpe de
estado del 25 de octubre no desempeñen
ningún papel en el gobierno de
transición
bienvenidos a un nuevo resumen de
noticias en francés 24 los saluda danger
hablando comenzamos hablando de los
presidentes de eeuu joe biden y de rusia
vladimir putin que sostuvieron este
jueves una conversación telefónica la
segunda del mes con ucrania como tema
clave en la agenda según la casa blanca
la conversación duró alrededor de 50
minutos previamente hablamos con
cristóbal vázquez en nuestro
corresponsal en washington para conocer
los detalles de esta llamada
si en la llamada que fue solicitada por
rusia eeuu volvió a dejarle claro a
moscú que apoya a ucrania ya su
soberanía el consejo de seguridad
nacional él dijo en esta llamada que el
tono de la conversación entre vladimir
putin y yo bailé fue un tono serio y
sustantivo y que yo bailén le planteo
básicamente dos caminos a vladimir putin
el primero es la diplomacia y que en ese
camino podría haber bastantes avances y
el segundo es el camino de las sanciones
de que si rusia termina invadiendo a
ucrania podría haber grandes sanciones
económicas no solamente de parte de eeuu
sino también de los aliados europeos
hacia rusia y también ayuda militar a
ucrania al respecto a la jefe de prensa
también publicó un comunicado la jefe de
prensa de la casa blanca james aquí
diciendo que eeuu tomará acciones
definitivas y concretas en caso de una
posible invasión hay que recordar que
hay cerca de 100.000 tropas rusas en la
frontera entre ucrania y rusia también
se habló en esta llamada que pues el
objetivo principal de esta era plantear
el marco y la agenda de lo que serán las
próximas reuniones diplomáticas en enero
nos quedamos en ese país porque al menos
seis personas resultaron heridas a causa
de los incendios forestales que azotan
al condado de boulder ubicado a las
afueras de denver la capital de colorado
los incendios voraces en el estado
algunos provocados por la caída de
cables eléctricos
impulsaron a los gobiernos de las
ciudades de superior y lo vivió a
ordenar la evacuación de al menos 30 mil
habitantes las autoridades estiman que
unas 508 casas un hotel y un centro
comercial quedaron incendiados
en brasil alrededor de una veintena de
muertos y 50.000 desplazados son parte
del saldo de las intensas lluvias en el
país unas de 600 mil personas se han
visto afectadas por el fenómeno que
azota principalmente al estado de bahía
desde finales de noviembre la
gobernación del estado estima que se
necesita el equivalente a 70 millones de
dólares para construir unas 5 mil
viviendas para los damnificados
hasta estábamos muy asustados era
catastrófico aquí en la calle cuando
llegué a la casa tenía agua hasta el
ombligo había mucha agua
cuando llegué las casas aún no se habían
derrumbado entonces todo cayó
debe haber 15 casas destruidas aquí
perdimos todo todos aquí se quedaron sin
nada
en noticias de la pandemia que parece no
dar tregua hoy se registró un nuevo
récord mundial de contagios de kobe de
19 en el mundo la organización mundial
de la salud reportó en las últimas de 24
horas algo más de un millón 350 mil
casos de kobe de 19 en todo el planeta
una cifra diaria que pulveriza todos los
registros hasta ahora vistos en dos años
de pandemia detrás de estas cifras está
la combinación de la incidencia de las
variantes delta y omicron del virus y
por primera vez no están directamente
relacionadas con aumentos en las muertes
y la organización mundial de la salud
cree que al menos 82 países no van a
lograr cumplir la meta de tener al 40
por ciento de la población completamente
vacunada contra el cob y de 19 para el
cierre de 2021 en medio de este poco
alentador panorama y israel toma la
delantera el ministerio de salud anunció
el inicio de la segunda vacunación de
refuerzo este país fue el más ágil en
implementar hace un año la vacunación
para toda su población y también uno de
los primeros en introducir las dosis
complementarias cayó y saudí & matan
asiste una juventud keystone he aprobado
la cuarta dosis de la vacuna a los
inmunodeprimidos personas con
enfermedades y tratamientos que afectan
al sistema inmune lo he hecho con base
en investigaciones que demuestran el
beneficio de las vacunas incluida la
cuarta dosis para esa población y a la
luz de las crecientes preocupaciones de
que esta población es más vulnerable a
la variante o micro
portu todo lo mejor y de israel vamos a
sudar al menos cuatro personas murieron
por disparos de la policía en este país
durante las manifestaciones contra el
gobierno militar los manifestantes
exigen que quienes tomaron el control a
final de octubre abandonen el ejecutivo
[Aplausos]
desafiando los bloqueos el apagón de las
comunicaciones y los gases lacrimógenos
miles de personas volvieron a las calles
de jartúm
pero todo el mundo sabe que los jefes
militares en metetí y albur hands son
nombres del antiguo dictador bashir
hasta hoy no se ha logrado ninguno de
los objetivos de la revolución de mi
novela allá nos manifestamos por la
caída del poder militar y contra el
reciente acuerdo político se suponía que
iba a poner fin al derramamiento de
sangre pero por desgracia las muertes y
la violencia continúan inicialmente
puesto bajo arresto domiciliario tras el
golpe de estado del 25 de octubre el
primer ministro destituido abdellah
handbook fue restituido a finales del
mes pasado después de haber llegado a un
acuerdo de reparto del poder dijo que
era un paso importante y necesario para
lograr la paz pero el acuerdo provocó la
ira de los manifestantes que denunciaron
la medida como una traición exigen que
los militares no desempeña ningún papel
en el gobierno durante la transición a
las elecciones libres que el acuerdo
promete celebrar en 2023 el jueves fue
el undécimo día de grandes
manifestaciones desde el golpe a pesar
de la dura respuesta a las fuerzas de
seguridad se han instalado nuevas
cámaras de vigilancia ya que el consejo
soberano de sudán otorgó esta semana
amplios poderes al servicio de
inteligencia del según el comité central
de médicos de sudán desde octubre ha
muerto unas cuatro docenas de personas a
causa de la represión policial la onu
afirma que al menos 13 mujeres y niñas
fueron violadas durante las protestas a
principios de este mes
terminamos en francia en el distrito 2
de parís artistas y asociaciones
dedicadas a ayudar a los emigrantes se
tomaron un edificio desocupado en este
lugar está abierta al público una
exposición 'la desde hace varias semanas
veamos de qué se trata en la calle son
denis en parís nació hace poco más de 15
días un colectivo que reúne a artistas y
asociaciones que brindan ayuda a los
refugiados blasco es uno de los artistas
que participan en el colectivo y tiene
sensibilizar a la opinión pública sobre
los problemas de la migración
aunque vengo del graffiti que es un arte
de lo instantáneo me parece que el hecho
de volver a las cosas reales y también
de escribir esta sociedad esta
actualidad es ponerlo en las paredes
ponerlo en una pizarra es importante
sólo mandarlos a moto
así que estoy aquí para dar fuerza a los
refugiados aunque sea por poco tiempo
para darles un poco de ánimo
ah
la exposición tiene lugar en un edificio
de 5 plantas un gran espacio donde los
visitantes pueden moverse libremente por
un lugar dedicado a la creación como es
miembro de la asociación united muy
grandes para él es urgente renovar los
edificios abandonados para los más
necesitados
aquí hoy en el edificio tenemos una
veintena de personas alojadas que han
podido encontrar un techo esas personas
viven en la calle o son víctimas de
gente que se aprovecha de su situación
en realidad la idea es que cuando hay
edificios vacíos se ponga a disposición
de quienes más los necesitan
la exposición es efímera y a partir del
primero de enero comenzará a acoger a
familias refugiadas durante 15 días así
la idea es acompañar a los migrantes
durante el inicio de 2022
me parece muy bien que haya artistas que
se movilicen así por este tipo de causas
es algo muy fuerte aunque es algo
temporal les permite pasar un periodo de
invierno en el refugio la ciudad de
parís planea entonces reorganizarse para
acoger con urgencia a las mujeres y a
los niños que más lo necesitan
[Música]
hasta que este resumen informativo feliz
noche para todos
[Música]